[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers no
winners nobody's found him to say I know
we don't make him alright well tonight
tonight a fan with the screen name I
love Richard Nixon thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
recent comedy sketch about the US
citizenship test hi Conan I think I may
have spotted an error on tonight's show
at one point you went and you were doing
a bit where he was asking you questions
about the United States history one of
those questions was which US President
had an affair with an intern in the
White House which passed u.s. President
had sex with an intern in the White
House all of them except Nixon you said
all of them except for Richard Nixon now
we all know that can't be true because
George Washington our first president
never actually lived in the White House
so it looks like you may have some
explaining to do
I'm sorry I love Richard Nixon by the
way to reassure you Richard Nixon would
have loved you pal Peter everything yeah
especially everything he stood yeah
you're fantastic work in silence of the
land yeah that was amazing green man no
one's getting out of your face
well anyway pal I'm really sorry you're
dead wrong you see George Washington did
sleep with an intern in the White House
now it's true that John Adams was the
first president to live in the White
House in 1800 and it's true that
Washington died a full year before the
White House was completed but you're
still wrong and I have proof
check out this rare archival footage
of the White House under construction in
1799 this is the place I'm telling you
about
hey don't mind us fellas just giving
this intern a tour of the future White
House President Washington and look I
know you're building this fancy house
for John Adams but damn it I was the
first president and I'm gonna be the
first president to screw an intern in
the White House yes sir
great now get in bed Dolores at your
service time to visit the Washington
Monument that's right I refer to my
penis as the Washington Monument
I cannot tell a lie I just had an orgasm
[Applause]
[Music]
another little-known fun fact George
Washington was apparently from Queens
yeah hey everybody George Washington
anyway we're right again and you're
wrong so the challenge still stands if
you think you've spotted an error on our
show reported at team koco.com / haha
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chuck meat out of
the maestro